hallo leute ich hier ist wieder jürgen
klopp und dann kommt zu einer neuen
folge wie schmeckt ich glaube dass und
auch nicht weil ich euch jetzt alles so
sehr wieder gewünscht habt machen wir
heute den saft der gummibärenbande zum
ibm helfen hier und dort und überall ich
habe auf youtube eine folge gefunden in
der sie ungefähr erklären was in diesen
saft drei machen uns war es die neunte
folge keine ahnung ob es von der ersten
staffel ist oder von hits zweiten
extreme ob staffeln gummibären wandel
immer noch während bmw die langweilig
und was sie immer bei diesem gummibären
saft haben ist so ein grund flüssigkeit
die liga ist und ich dachte das kann ja
einfach nur traubensaft sein weil der es
auch lila und da würde ich sagen müssen
jetzt alle erstes den einmal aufwärmen
[Musik]
ok es nicht schon mal sehr gut
es riecht wie eine kirche das müssen wir
den induktionsherd wenn wir noch nie
bedient haben an machen bestimmt jetzt
warten wir darauf dass und traubensaft
das ist doch das dümmste was im wald
rumläuft wenn der jetzt kocht dann
geht's an die richtigen zutaten so
richtig aus über den bären
[Musik]
also die die beeren die sie da rein
machen sind gummibären da es keine
gummibären gibt dachte ich hole ich
einfach gummibären und wir brauchen
zuerst sechs rote dafür habe ich so eine
beere mischung geholt
herbert denk kleinkinder immer wenn ihr
braucht probieren du sechs handvoll
roter beeren hinein sechs rote beeren
und viel spaß da sind wollen mag ich aus
und vier orange farbe nach der orangen
abgelehnt habe und drei purpurrote was
sind wohl rote ich glaube es ist
passiert
das sieht mir nach popo gut aus sie
kommen jetzt auch noch dazu wenn und
jetzt vier blaue saphir blaue für die
blauen habe ich die besten durch 444
hübsches sie seien bereit explosion und
drei grüne und drei grüne für die kühe
habe ich nie eingeholt die englischen
die hessen wieder wenn du mich so heißen
sie oder ich glaub man nicht englisch
sowie kommen jetzt auch noch daran
also die rezepte hier die werden immer
seriöse auf jeden fall und eine gelbe
ein gelbe so einer gelben er also zuerst
musst du ganz langsam nach rechts rühren
und dann ganz langsam nachlässt und am
ende
logisch einmal auf die seite dann blasen
aufsteigen ja das ist eigentlich das
rezept ich es gemacht wird eine kleine
flasche besorgt weil sie auch immer eine
serie so eine kleine flasche haben also
wenn sie von den großen treuen weglaufen
und nicht schnell genug sind dann machen
sich ihre flasche auf und bringen neben
boni werden saft und das müssen wir auch
tun wir trauern kraft riecht nicht mehr
nach traubensaft erdig nach irgendwie
traumhaft und brot und jetzt müssen wir
den abfüllen damit wir den gleichen die
flasche füllen können vorsicht heiß und
hier habt ihr euren leckeren gummibären
saft von dem wir hoffentlich super stark
werdet weil wir menschen dem trägt dann
werden sie ganz kurz vor start der muss
jetzt definitiv abkühlen cool gibt eine
richtige flasche heißt das ist unser
fertiger gummibären saft und der muss
jetzt noch abkühlen und danach geht's
ans probieren
lasst euch verzaubern von ihrem
geheimnis der saft bringt die kraft
teurer macht
ok also aussehen tut es auf jeden fall
schon mal wieder gummibären saft riechen
na ja und jetzt stellen wir uns
natürlich wieder der allerwichtigsten
frage wie schmeckt der gummibären saft
aus disneys gummibärenbande prost ein
stück für mama i mutig und freundlich so
tapfer und gläubig in in den welt und da
sind sie zu hause bin hier und dort und
überall
sie riefen für dich denken kann man da
von super aber schmecken tut es echt
richtig scheiße also nicht nachmachen
das reicht schon dass ich das gemacht
wie immer hoffen natürlich dass euch die
folge gefallen hat und wenn ihr noch
weitere rezeptvorschläge habt aus filmen
und serien dann immer her damit etwas
hat es in die kommentare
ich wünsche euch eine schöne woche post
hmm lecker